sorry uh I don't think um yes can you
hear me yeah yeah go ahead
um I I don't think uh there's a a real
solution until women start marching and
changing laws and
they're the ones that kind of have to
change the culture because they're not
they're not listening to men generally
speaking women have no idea what men
want
um so until they start learning what men
want and they start changing the laws in
the culture I don't think there's an
immediate solution I think it'll
probably take a whole nother generation
what do you think should women
marry before they carry
yes
and that and I think that would be a
start you know like
if they're not you know having you know
you know body count of 10 20 or hundreds
and they're having only seriously or
serious relationships
um that would be a start
but
it would have to be it's going to take
time you know like
I think a lot of the guys that are
calling like um like the Mormon guy a
lot of the religious stuff is always
mentioned and that's that's not a
solution uh that's been mentioned for at
least a generation and that's why guys
don't go to church generally speaking
anymore is because you know there's a
whole bunch of single mothers or used up
women you know who wouldn't be good
wives you know they're not wives so I
think the stars that women have to
become wives
and take relationships seriously because
they're the ones that I think
disproportionately get affected more
it's actually pretty sad
um
how women are kind of doing this to
themselves you know that they've been
lied to with all the feminism and
everything
and
you know a lot of the guests are calling
you know saying that marriage is
uh best for society which is true
but
you know
I don't you know that's kind of like
blue pill thinking you know like we're
like yeah that's the best for society
but that's just putting everything on
hope you know and it's not long so you
know so if marriage isn't changed things
so if marriage isn't a good deal for men
today how can women require marriage
before they carry
if a reasonable man it seems like a guy
a reasonable guy wouldn't get married
that's true
um I see it and that's why I say it's
going to take a long time there's going
to be a lot of women unfortunately that
will probably have to be hurt and you
know and not be able to have you know
families or marriage until you know the
story gets out or it affects the culture
to where guys are like oh you know so
and so dump me you know like we're you
know it's kind of like a common story or
a common theme you know where guys are
constantly running into this you know
where
women only want to date seriously and so
on and so forth
um
but I think a huge Plus for women would
be to
you know then get together and and start
changing laws I mean there's been a
couple of successes here and there in
certain states in America but as a whole
it's it's not getting any better anytime
soon
well thank you for calling in I
appreciate it
what are you using is it just WhatsApp
did you answer um hi this is Pearl
you're live on the air
yo yo finale harder to find a virgin in
the streets and get on this call excuse
my language
solution to Modern dating going
uh number one uh everything that happens
in society falls on the man so uh men
have to stop being samps
um they're complaining about laws on the
books
they got to start reading and uh change
the laws on the book getting positions
of power out here in California there's
too many uh no offense but there's too
many females in positions of power you
know and it's because men have been a
accustomed to
watching video games instead of working
on houses and uh you know watching
sports and [ __ ] all day long
um so for the average guy that doesn't
want to get into politics should he get
married
uh I would say uh
probably not just because uh most men
they can't handle women
as far as like uh the average man you
know and I think that's a problem with
the red pill space is that a
they teach her like oh yeah oh man can
uh can handle women and everything but
not really like I mean they try to use
biblical examples but most of the men in
the biblical days they were uh they were
pretty much like kings they had harems
of a whole bunch of women so the average
man was a slave for the most part you
know
what do you think should women marry
before they carry
yeah I do agree with that because uh
marriages are the the backbone to
society you know so if you're uh if
you're carrying somebody's uh seed who
you can to
can't see a future with it doesn't
really make sense right how long should
a woman wait till marriage or how long
should a woman wait to get marriage
before cutting it off
I'd say like one of the other guys said
probably like around like two or three
years two or three years it just depends
on how uh good a relationship she has
with her father because if she doesn't
have a good relationship with her father
then
yeah it's over it's over with pretty
much okay
so you think the solution going forward
average guys shouldn't get married
women no but women should get married
before they carry but and they should
leave after three years
well I wouldn't necessarily the average
guy shouldn't get married I would just
like go in a little deeper uh in detail
with that and say the average men
shouldn't expect it you know average man
the thing is like what the red pill
space too is like they how they hype up
all these land mass dudes and it's like
bro like you don't even know how to
change your oil on your vehicle [ __ ]
like that you know and it's like how do
you I mean there's an old saying that my
grandpa used to tell me you know if you
want your wife to stay in the kitchen
you better know how to build and
maintain the kitchen right you know so
simple as that you know as if you don't
know if you don't know what you're doing
don't expect good results
okay thank you for calling in
all right have a good one all right um
give it a second blessing
someone in the chat
here's the solution and it says right in
the vowels to death do us part
who are these women marrying themselves
okay you can do another one you can let
them call in
yeah I don't know how we get rid of the
beeping we have to figure that out for
next show hi this is Pearl you're live
on the air
hello this is Pearl you're live on the
air
oh hello Hi how are you
I'm good thank you it was really easy to
get on
what is the solution to Modern dating
going forward
okay
so the solution to Modern dating is
really the younger generation needs to
understand how much our promiscuous
Lifestyles have messed up gen Z like
everybody is so mentally and emotionally
damaged and they have trust issues and
daddy issues and broken families and all
of these bad things and I think the
younger generation needs to like just
completely re-virginize
and just wait until marriage to have sex
okay so kind of say the older people
you're too far gone
you you it's it's over with done with
but the young people wait till you're
married
yeah you know I mean
I would like to say that there's hope
for the older people I just think that
you know gen Z is just damaged already
like a lot of the damage has been done
and so I think to kind of fix the dating
arena is to kind of look ahead and look
towards the younger generation and
hopefully because I kind of see you know
like there's this pattern of the younger
generation learns from the older
generation and so I think they'll kind
of see how we've messed that up and then
hopefully they'll just wait until
they're married until they get married
to have sex I mean if you really think
about it like just hypothetically
speaking imagine if everybody in the
world waited until marriage to have sex
or at least everybody in America and I
know you're in the UK but like if
everybody just waited until marriage to
have sex like how much
how much less problems there would be
like there would be less Brokenness less
cheating less trust issues there would
be less kids out of wedlock there'd be
less abortion I mean we could talk about
contraception too because I know you've
had a lot to say on that and I agree
with you in a lot of ways so what do you
think that men should sign the marriage
contract with a virgin
with the incentives that pay women to
leave
you know
let's see
I think I think yeah like I think if
they can find a good wholesome girl I
mean I'm religious and I'm I'm a
traditional woman I've got a husband
I've got two kids I'm only 23. like you
know and we have a great marriage so I
think
if people can if men can find a good
girl who is
most likely religious because let's be
honest that's where they are
and they're virgins when they get
married and they value like traditional
outcomes you know like they want to be
there for the husband support their
husband they want to be their peace and
do all the things that men want
then I say why not if you know that This
Woman's never going to leave you then
why not as long as you're in it together
so if so you think that men should only
marry virgins
I could be wrong I'm just asking do you
think like they should only offer that
contract to women that are virgins
not only I don't think only because I
think there are a lot of women
um myself included who were not virgins
when we got married but we were kind of
lied to by
by you know the whole secular media and
everybody around us who was not virgins
when they got married and you kind of
get lied to and you're sold this lie as
long as you don't believe in the lie and
you understand that that's not the way
to go and the things that you've done
are wrong in your past but you have to
be willing to accept the fact that you
are wrong and you're going to be better
moving forward because I do believe that
people can change so then do you think
that they should wait till they're
married moving forward
yeah I think so I mean even if you have
a high body count like where you're just
gonna be like if it
is she still there I think it kind of
just oh there your body count
I think that's only gonna hear me yeah I
hear you sorry you cut out for a second
can you hear me yeah yeah okay yeah
I actually cut out again just keep
upping their body count already high
well yeah but why would a guy marry a
girl like wouldn't he kind of be a simp
then like if the last guy got to hit it
for free last 10 guys got to hit it for
free and then he marries her like that
that like because I think this is a lot
of the issue that men have with like
women that are religious is like you
were kind of encouraging bad deals for
men
oh
um wait hold on wait did you already
accept it
oh yeah okay okay because here's the
thing like
that's that's the problem is like a lot
of times as women I just think we're
really attached to the idea of marriage
and it's not a great deal for men if
you're not a virgin to wait like why
would a guy wait for you and will you
really respect him if he does
and I mean people people can say they
will but I've seen the way these girls
move around their husbands in the church
a lot of times a lot of times but
you know maybe it is the solution I
don't know
um you can open the call as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible